[Music]
[Applause]
i was looking at jim jackson's uh career
numbers he of course nba on tnt also uh
a clippers analyst he'll be broadcasting
the fort worth region of the ncaa
tournament tomorrow march madness games
until the end of the month and uh he
joins us on the program i got you for a
career high
50. jim
50 yeah 50.
what did 50 feel like
uh you know but ironically i was sick
because we were in denver so the night
before i couldn't sleep and plus the
altitude had me all stopped up so i had
to actually run my shower
to get moisture in the room just so i
could breathe so the next day i shoot
around
i just wasn't feeling it went to sleep
and and then when the game started uh
actually i wasn't paying any attention i
was just i was just bald now keep in
mind like right before that couple weeks
before jamal
mashburn had 50 points in chicago at the
united center
so in that game i had it it was uh in
denver it ended up going into overtime
but
um again i didn't shoot a lot of threes
though so mine were more layups
mid-range jump shots free throws i only
think i had a three-pointer that game
but you look at what kyrie did last
night he had 60
and still had seven and a half minutes
to go
why not just leave him in there
because it's not like fatigue because he
may not play for a couple more games and
whoever comes in for kyrie is going to
be shooting shots so
if you're kyrie if you're steve nash do
you say stay out there let's see what
you can do no no
unwritten rule because they were upbeat
so it was no need for kyrie but wait
wait if patty mills comes in jim then
patty mills is going to be taking those
shots instead of kyrie yeah but but but
patty mills doesn't have 60.
you see what i'm saying i mean now as as
crazy as it sounds it's just one of
those things that
coaches have respect for other coaches i
remember i was in high school it was the
same kind of thing
where
i had 50 and i still had about four or
five minutes left in the game the
opposing coach
used to work for my high school coach
and we were up big i mean we were 120 30
points something like that the game was
out of reach
so i got the record but my coach said
you know enough is enough because i have
respect for the other team and the other
coach and i'm not if somebody else comes
in and knocks in some points okay that's
fine but it's not like you're kind of
kind of just digging your heel in a
little bit more now you'll see that when
you know it's personal between two
coaches two organizations two franchises
where they'll go for two when they don't
really have to they'll go for a
touchdown
uh when they're up big anyway just to
make a point that's when it's personal
well kobe was helped out because the
lakers were down big
starting the third quarter against
toronto
and then he goes for 55 in the second
half against the raptors
yeah almost like though to his last game
i was at the last game that he played
and about the third quarter i was about
to leave because i you know me i'm i'm
lazy i like to try to be trafficked
to get out of staples center but
something told me to stay and because
it's his last game
utah had found out that no matter what
happened they weren't going to be in a
position from the playoff perspective
where they wanted to be so the game
really didn't mean anything
so keeping colby in to score those
points and do what he had to do it was
more monumental it wasn't a sign of
disrespect they were actually playing
homage to kobe
if his last that was his last game
especially at the time staples center
and in the league so that's a whole
different dynamic that i think everybody
the opposing team utah lakers everybody
bought into totally different you know
what i mean is 60 the new 50
seems like it doesn't
but here's the thing though dan you know
this you got more possessions you're
utilizing the three-point line a lot
more so you're gonna get more shots up
okay the way the game is being played
today and i get
you know a lot of time i grew up because
in the 90s the possessions were low so
you were scoring 70 80 points okay
because each one was kind of grinded out
you had some teams that you know got up
and down the court but for the most part
you know you play the half court game so
you can't be surprised at the numbers
you're putting up in regards to total
team points but individuals have to
score but and i caution people about
this all the time dan whether you see it
in football baseball hockey basketball
professional you're all trying to score
more points okay you want to hit more
home runs you want us more you want to
score more more goals you want to throw
more touchdowns why because the fans
enjoy that it's more exciting to see we
can't be locked into what the game used
to be because internationally has grown
so much as a global game and people want
it so as much as we love the 90s and
early 2000s this is the way the game is
today and these young men that are
playing that's all they know so i can't
bought them for that
do you think we'll see somebody get 80
again
oh definitely
i think so
too many possessions in the game pick
one guy
kevin durant
i guess he i can see kd getting it i
just don't know if he's greedy enough
you know what you're right but it
depends on the situation too if he gets
off to an early start let's say he has
30 or 40 at halftime and the game is in
balance and he keeps going back and
forth what kd is going to go for in
regards to one wanting to win the game
because he's just a basketball servant
he loves to play the game and he wants
to win
so i can see kyrie getting close because
kyrie is just an assassin he's just
gonna go for it you know what i mean
he really is giannis i'm not for sure
yet because he can get 50 but because
the three ball doesn't have the same
effect he's not going to be able to
gobble up those points like a kyrie or a
um you know kevin durant or even a step
how did the nets incorporate ben simmons
here
by the end of the regular season
to be formidable once they get into the
postseason
well first of all dan is not
on the court is his mind right i don't
care what you do
[Music]
physically
game plan wise put him in a position but
if his mind is not right ready to play
then it doesn't matter and and i think
that's the most important part you got
to address with ben simmons is he
talented of course
i mean
not having a jump shot all of that kind
of stuff we saw what he could do when
he's really on top of his game in
particular when mb didn't play
totally different player yeah
but
with the
mental issues that he you know he
addressed
are you able to tap into that side where
he's mentally able to to really come
back and play the game at a high level
because if he is it's easy to intricate
integrate him into the game because he's
going to play the point guard position
he's going to rebound pass and play
defense you don't have to score
so
putting him into a lineup with kd
kyrie on the road is this inserting a
point guard that wants to be a pass for
his point guard but he got to be
mentally he got to be mentally rightful
talking to jim jackson nba on tnt fox
analyst also an analyst for the clippers
i'm surprised now jim when i wake up and
i saw what the lakers did that they won
like i i expect them to lose now yeah
yeah can you
let's say a.d comes back no can't just
is the season over for the lakers
i'm not going to say it's over because
the play-in game if they're still you
know the top 10 provide you an
opportunity
to do something so you can never say
it's over especially when you have
lebron james and if you have a healthy a
d that comes back with enough games
under his belt depending on where you
slot at if you're 10 and you had to play
seven
um
how that matchup works now that matchup
may be i don't know i think it's maybe
minnesota right there in seventh right
now i think which is a tough one for the
lake
that's tough
um but it's not insurmountable but
i just think there's so much going on
and again dad you've been around us
enough to know this
internally what is being said
we don't know that on the outside and
again i think the lakers have done a
great job outstanding job of keeping
whatever is being said
inside which is hard to do in today's
world
so you really don't know what the
conversations are
inside that locker room other than the
speculations that everybody on the
outside has
i think you were at ohio state three
years
how many tournament games did you play
uh my let me see so
my freshman year we got to
the second round 32 so that's two
my third my second year three sweet 16
5. 9.
got a game that sticks out
well yeah well two really
to it
congratulations on michigan winning this
year too by the way
um you don't mean that
you don't mean no no i do actually don't
you know then i do i'm gonna tell you
why
parody bro because
for that rivalry to have some substance
meat it has to be competitive it wasn't
competitive i'm ohio state guys don't
get me wrong and i'd love to win it
but in order to have drama okay the
other side has to win
and it's great for the big ten so that
leads me into the elite eight game that
we lost to michigan the bad five and the
reason why is because we beat them twice
during the year we were the number one
seed in the midwest
and that hurt from the simple fact that
you know it was we had an opportunity to
get to the final four now you know how
tough it is to beat a team three times
in a row and particularly a young team
like michigan that had nothing to lose
the other game that stands out to me is
the year before in the sweet 16 up in
detroit
we lost to st john we lost pretty bad
they were more we were physical they
were physical we thought we had the team
that really could get to a national
championship but unfortunately
you know it just was a bad matchup for
us so those two games stand out to me
who talked the most trash on that
michigan team in that tournament game
too jaylen
[Laughter]
and jalen is my guy
here's the thing jalen chris jawan jimmy
and ray are all great friends i played
with i played with juwan in houston
played with chris in sacramento
jayla and i used to work out a lot in
l.a jimmy king was in in camp with us in
the mavericks and i and during aau
season when my son was playing and
everything you see ray jackson all the
time so those guys to me were at the
time a rival
you know they became adversaries but
they became friends okay
and but jaylen thought was no question
bro if anybody jawon was quiet chris
would get hyped
jimmy would say some stuff but it was
always jaylen always talking no no doubt
did you recruit chris webber to ohio
state
no
yeah he had no chance pretty much what
perry watched with perry watson at at
michigan it was pretty much
kind of new
that uh chris was probably going to stay
either michigan state with his own but
uh
i knew he wasn't going to do because he
wasn't the duke he didn't have in his
mind but um i knew with perry watson at
michigan
that was almost like a no-brainer tom
tom izzu said he cried when he lost
chris webber
yeah
yeah
i mean
i mean yeah i mean that's that's he's a
game changer in regards to college at
that time because he's such a hybrid
player i always thought that juan
howard's a little bit more skilled
okay at the time
polished yeah chris was still raw and
his talent was just off the off the
charts and what he was in he bought a
certain energy to
his team into the game itself and that's
what
separated chris at the time to be six
nine six ten to handle it and especially
this the iq
to be able to make plays and pass now
the iq may have hurt him a little bit
with the timeout i'm not paying
attention to what was going on or what
happened don't get me wrong but i mean
and and that's a flaw that he had but up
here
an understanding when i played with him
in sacramento unbelievable off the
charts bro
did you play against duke
i wish i would have now if we were to
beat michigan we would have played
cincinnati and ultimately if we would be
in cincinnati we would have played
um well no did you hear it it would have
been north carolina
did you hate well i had
no no here's the thing i had a beef with
with coach k
because i got i got an eagle so my going
into my sophomore year the goodwill
games were being
put together so i go try out
and um i'm playing i'm playing well um i
get down to the final cut
and i'm in my room
and you get that early call in the
morning bro it's like come see coach i'm
like oh what get in there and they cut
me
so they kept brian stiff at the time acc
and brian was good in college but to me
i'm like man he
not better than me i played better and i
held a grudge because that was the first
time i ever got cut
you know what i'm saying so
i didn't care too much are you over it
jim jim are you over getting cut can you
catch your tail
and we and we had a gate we had a game
uh duke
john's uh in the garden a few years back
and i pulled coach k to the side
i said you know i still got a little
beef with you
just because uh i mean i never got cut
so to me that was like
i'm going back and i'm going back to my
room and i'm like
i just got cut
i'm not now it fueled me it gave me
a different perspective on the game
itself
um which energized me that whole summer
in the next year
but i looked at the duke now i have much
respect for what they've done
i mean christian laden is probably one
of the greatest college players to ever
play the game bobby hurley grant hill
you can't take that away but yeah i
carried a little
it hurt a little bit right there
it's always great to catch up with you
have fun during the tournament we'll be
uh we'll be listening
all right brother appreciate you man
that's a jim jackson nba on tnt clippers
fox analyst